there's CGI in the season by the way yes
I know you've ever seen playback I go
wait where's he where's how does the CGI
come into playback we have a fox in the
final uh episode of the second season
and foxes that are uh you know they're
everywhere in London they come out at
night and they've got a Swagger and you
could I mean they're kind of they own
the city at night and so I'd written
this this fox that comes in looks at
fleabag with this kind of wise look in
his eye and sort of naively I was like
yeah we'll just you know get a couple of
real foxes and just give them the notes
and uh we've got a really good director
and the script is strong you know
they'll be fine I need two terrified
Little Country foxes turned up and they
literally came out and they were like
what the hell is this place yeah and
then the only way to calm them down was
to play Coldplay but then eventually
they would come out and they'd Scrabble
around and we got like a snout in one
shot and a bit of a tail on the other as
they were running around so it was going
to we ended up having to get a cartoon
he went that way